like what oh thanks amazing the sad
thing is is that this doesn't shock me I
don't know why I read that one all right
uh hmm I met a guy on tinder and went to
his house for a barbecue he proceeded to
get high and then streaked around his
backyard that's actually amazing that's
incredible that's a great time there's a
part of me that thinks well you know at
least she got a sneak preview
added this sounds like fun I would have
also gotten hi and joined him so mmm he
sounds like a good time haven't called
me next one I was speaking to this guy
on tinder first mistake and after only a
few minutes he asked me if I would marry
him for $10,000 no joke apparently he
wanted to become an American citizen
I've had this happen to me
I was just like walking to the bus stop
one time and this guy was like $1,000
and I was like for what and he was like
to marry you and I was like no that's
not that bad of a horror story I have to
say I mean if I would love to be offered
$10,000 to marry somebody easily yes yo
I'm just saying I need ten stacks I
don't know anybody who doesn't need ten
stacks many guy who seemed to be decent
huh classic story we went to see a movie
and he kept talking about my feet and
the first sign how beautiful and sexy he
thought they were I was like thanks
later during the movie he asked if he
could suck on my toes have some freaking
class you're taking it to a movie first
of all lame how do you even adjust your
feet in a way because you're both
sitting so do you scoot over and you
lift your feet up and then he just sucks
on them in the movie you could even wait
til we left the movie theater does he
eat popcorn while sucking on the toes
then your toes get buttery and moist in
that way as well relatable once after my
divorce even
match me up with my ex-husband MCM
that's it that's all there is
holy crap Wow I mean maybe to her match
it is especially awkward when you see
people that you've dated in the past on
apps I think I saw my ex's profile and I
was like really the same photos when we
dated maybe eat harmony know something
that y'all don't clearly I was getting
back into dating when I agreed to go to
coffee with the sky he told me 15
minutes and that he'd broken up with his
ex because she asked to sleep without
his cats in bed he said I told her the
cats were there first so she's yeah you
get mr. cat man over here you know what
I appreciate this guy because he's like
hey it's my cats or nothing I mean if
you ain't down with it then get moving
these are his cats and like they've been
there longer than you have I once had a
date canceled on me when I was already
in route because the guy wanted to take
a nap so yes I ate sushi alone the night
that sounds like a good night this is my
favorite that's great I'm really happy
I'm really happy that they did that this
isn't a horror story this is like an
ideal scenario
no no that's so rude I feel like I have
canceled enroute dates and I'm not proud
of it but also we haven't met so I am
someone who cancels her naps so I get I
get I did this painting we were supposed
to go to brunch but when he came to pick
me up he said we were going to church
all right it's totally different
what is bottomless mimosas and you can't
drink in the other one I'm not a
religious person but he guaranteed that
we'd get food after at church he
introduced me to his whole family as his
girlfriend look I'd be sucked in by food
too right like I'd be like oh well good
food after all right fine whatever I'll
go to church with the old tolerate it
was awkward this is kind of sad awkward
that I think that the biggest
disappointment is that you might hold
man we're gonna memo set it up and then
we're turning up on Jesus's blood I
don't it's not the same turn up last one
my date invited me to his house where he
was supposed to cook me dinner when I
arrived he asked for a ride to Ikea
because he just sold his dining room
table on Craigslist and needed another I
found out then that he didn't have a car
afterward he asked if I wanted to stay
the night because he had a job interview
in the morning that he needed a ride to
this guy probably like smokes a lot of
weed and like has a skateboard - yo this
guy is just looking for a sugar mama
like he's looking for a hook-up boy
I like to think that this guy just does
this he just goes on dates when he needs
to run errands who was the person that
falls for this like you know what yeah I
will stay the night sleep with you and
then drive you around like that is the
best lyft service ever
oh god what a loser definitely
skateboards probably doesn't even have a
bed frame this guy's mattress is on the
floor overall this is this just shows
how low the bar is set for men where I
just need to be generally nice and not
send a picture of my penis and I think
I'm on the higher grade of dudes which
is completely and utterly sad I guess
maybe we all just need to be like what
are your fetishes before I go on this
date if he shows up then we have decent
conversation and I don't feel
uncomfortable then that's like an A+
state to me this doesn't you feel better
than that dating because this is the
world they trashed this is a pile of
trash also it's fine to be single like I
think being okay with being single is
the best way to find someone I just want
to do so learn to be okay being off I'm
hoping that us joking around about these
weirdos stories will shine some light on
people and how to properly treat each
other but yeah overall good luck
Godspeed and good luck out there because
it is a jungle but just know you are
worth it and if you
sucking toes just be respectful about it
and then the skateboarding guy I just
can't I can this is like this is
literally tinder and paper form
[Music]
[Music]